well for the awards to cinematographers
the artists who actually put movies on
film with a magical blending of light
cameras and photogenic people such as
Lana Turner and Lex Barker those
nominated for achievement cinematography
the black and white production are the
four-poster Stanley Kramer Columbia
photograph I held more from here to
eternity Columbia phonograph by Burnett
gusty Julius Caesar metro Golda Meir
photographed by Joseph Rutenberg Martin
Luther Louis de Rougemont associates
photographed by Joseph C Bruna Roman
Holiday paramount
photographed by Frank P planer and Henry
Alec on and who is the winner next
Burnett Caffrey for From Here to
Eternity
nominees for color cinematography are
all the brothers were valiant Metro
golda meir photographed by George faulty
beneath the 12-mile wreath 20th Century
Fox photographed by Edward cron Yeager
Lily metro Golda Meir photographed by
Robert Clank the robe 20th Century Fox
photographed by leon sham Roy Shan
paramount photographed by loyal Griggs
the winner please let the winner is
loyal Griggs for shame
now she's just beautiful I don't know
what you season him either somebody is
born with money I can decide